What if I told you that while you are
watching this short video, I'm going to
get at least one high ticket client
worth maybe about $3,000 in new revenue
without lifting a finger, taking a sales
call. Heck, I don't even have a sales
team. You see, the high ticket coaching
business I run and the way I run it gets
me about one to three high ticket
clients every single day without me
getting on a sales call or again having
a sales team. In fact, I only have an
executive assistant and manage up to 60
70 high ticket clients at any time solo
delivering worldclass results working
less than 4 hours a day. So, what kind
of voodoo magic is this? And I'll unpack
it all inside this video. But there's
two things that separate me from all the
other coaches and consultants that at my
revenue level are drowning in sales
conversations, delivery obligations, or
then managing a team. And what this is
is the quality of my ideas, the quality
of my decisions, and then essentially
the strategies, the playbooks that come
from those ideas. So, let's actually go
inside my vacation home and unpack this
all so you get to install it yourself.
Before we dive in, quick introduction.
My name is Malto for our consultant and
successful coaches and consultants come
to me when they want to sign an extra
one 123 high ticket clients every single
day through the daily client funnel that
does that on complete autopilot. A solo
entrepreneur who's making a million a
year isn't much different to any other
entrepreneur. I mean essentially we have
access to the same information to the
same internet. We have access to the
same 24 hours. We're bound to the same
laws. So really what is the big
difference is not even the routines.
Waking up at 5:00 a.m. or not, doing
yoga, doing ice bath. And while all of
those things might help, what it again
all really comes down to is just the
quality of ideas. one has and how we are
using those ideas to construct offers
using the strategies that we have access
to and are using the time that we have
inside a day. So when I am signing one
two three clients every single day
actively serving dozens and dozens of
clients with nothing but an assistant
and four hours of work a day. What it
comes down to is constructing efficient
ways to do all of that in as little time
as possible. So, some people might call
that smart work, but what it really is,
it's creative leverage. And that's
really what I want to speak about over
the next few minutes. So, let's run
through an actual typical day of mine.
And it's important to me that we aren't
just paying attention to what I'm
actually doing because that matters
less. It's much more about how it's
putting me into a situation into a
position where I can construct efficient
ways to do less but get more. So let's
look at it. So obviously like all of you
I got to wake up in the morning and I
care a lot about my sleep. So I sleep
about 7 hours. Then first thing first I
read something that was published before
Gutenberg and that's usually the Bible
that I read in the morning because it
grounds me and it provides me with
ancient wisdom. any of the problems that
I have, they were solved thousands of
years ago. So I I can find solutions in
the past. Then I have a dedicated block
for thinking. So I think for an hour a
day and for me that's closing my eyes
and observing my thoughts. That's it.
Nothing else. Some people might call
that meditation, but for me it's less
about focusing on my breath. It's really
just closing my eyes and paying
attention to my thoughts that come when
my eyes are closed and writing down
anything valuable that comes in the time
being. Right after I do a bit of
journaling and I'm doing like a bit of a
brain dump. So I'm writing down my
fears. I'm writing down my hopes. I'm
just doing like a brain dump so that I
can clear my brain and ultimately get
ready for walking 10,000 steps. So every
single day I walk 10,000 steps while
usually listening to an audio book or I
listen to like a YouTube video. I'm
starting to feed my brain with with good
input. I just cleared it right before
that activity. Now I can feed it with
good input and movement stimulates the
brain. Anyways, so then when I come
home, I usually have a bit of like
coffee and then I read for about 30
minutes and then I usually sit at my
desk for the first time and I write for
at least 60 minutes. Now, this isn't
like social media writing. I much more
want to turn my ideas and my thoughts
into concepts. concepts can be solutions
to problems that I either use for myself
or that I'm going to sell to my
customers or that I going to use for my
customers. And then really we come to
the core. There is a great book that's
called the one thing which is really
about that whole topic we're speaking
about today where essentially all after
that when I'm starting work I ask myself
what is the one thing I can do today
such that by doing it everything else
would be easier or unnecessary and I'm
thinking about that question for as long
as I have to up until I found the right
answer and when I do have that one thing
sometimes it's two three max I get that
done within about two to three hours and
this is a skill right so discover the
one crucial thing it comes down to
saying no to more things that you are
saying yes to at the moment so that when
those core things are done and that is
basically the deep work that I'm getting
done then I'm having about an hour or
though where I'm actually looking at my
inbox at my client messages, the you
know communication with my executive
assistant. So this one thing that I'm
doing plus the essentials like the
emails etc etc that ends up usually
being the 4 hours that I work and then
I'm pretty much done for the day. So I
guess now you can see how my entire
morning is spent to put myself in a
situation in a position where I can best
answer the question what's the one thing
and then get that done and by doing so
day after day week after week construct
efficient ways to do less inside my
business. So, now that we made the point
that essentially we're all running an
idea business and we're being paid for
the quality of of our ideas, it's really
all about having the best ideas
possible. And I found the best ideas
don't come by sitting at my desk, but
they come by enjoying the beauty that
life has to offer. So, the best ideas
for me, they come when I'm spending time
with my loved ones, when I'm spending
time on my own, when I'm going for a
hike, whatever that might be. They don't
come from grinding it out 16 hours a
day. Because when I do grind it out for
16 hours a day, I more so just execute
other people's ideas and other people's
greatness than listening to my own
greatness. Let's speak about some
concrete ideas that I've had that turn
into concepts that are now allowing me
to generate $3 to $6,000 a day. served
the many clients that I serve solo
basically with an executive assistant.
One of those is the messenger ready
offers. So early on when I started to
grow my business, the faster I grew, the
more sales calls I've had and
essentially I reached a point where I
was like this like I I can't continue
this. So I created the messenger ready
offer framework that allows me to sell
my high ticket offers without sales
conversations. Then number two, when I
signed all of those clients, the bigger
I got, the more time I spent in customer
fulfillment and that restricted the
growth of my business. So I created the
daily client rhythm that allows me to
serve high ticket clients in just like
50, 60, 70 high ticket clients in just 4
hours a week. And then lastly, we got
the client magnet. So instead of having
to produce free lead magnets, free
content all the time, I've created paid
client magnets that attracted my ideal
clients and turned those ideal clients
into buyers that generated cash flow,
but then also pre-sold my high ticket
programs that made the whole client
acquisitions a lot easier. Listen, I'm
not any special. I told you before that
a million-doll solo entrepreneur isn't
much different to any other
entrepreneur. We have the same 24 hours.
who have access to the same information.
We essentially don't have an unfair
advantage. We all just recognized early
on that we are in an idea business and
to succeed inside an idea business, we
need great ideas and great ideas need
time and space to develop. So, the
4-hour consultant, the 4-hour consulting
model where we strive to work the least
hours possible isn't because we're lazy
or we don't like to work. We're just
looking to spend as little time as
possible on those low leverage
activities. So, we can focus on turning
ideas into concepts that actually move
the needle and use our thinking to
create great life-changing offers and
strategies. This is the routine that
allows common entrepreneurs like you and
I to build $3 to $6,000 a day businesses
with nothing but an assistant and 4
hours of actual work. If you are
interested to learn more about the 4hour
consulting model, see if it is a fit for
you, then check out the link in the
description below. All right, if you
found value in this, then leave a
comment or leave a like. Hit the
subscribe button if you want to see
more. And I guess I see you in the next
video. This is Miles. Pe up.